down to the lead aide on Dancing with
the Stars and if there is one reason to
watch the show it's to see Army veteran
Noah Galloway what he is doing each and
every week with a prosthetic leg at half
an arm is mind-blowing it's also the
definition of inspiration remarkable
Cameron Mathison stopped by the Iraq war
heroes rehearsal I joined the military
because of September 11th you know I
went in dropped out of college enlisted
in the army and was an empty solder with
101st it was the invasion Iraq in 2003
loved what I was doing relisted went
back on my second deployment 2005 and
about three or four months into it was
hit by a roadside bomb and woke up six
days later in the hospital and lost two
of my limbs during that emotional and
physical difficult time you used working
out and training and getting in shape as
a way to help you overcome the
difficulty yeah that was you know I went
through a couple of years of depression
and struggled and it was hard because
there was no way to know how to work out
missing on the leg so I had to figure it
out and as a you know with each day week
month year just got better and better
barring his injuries while dancing with
Sharna has been a badge of honor I know
a few weeks ago you guys contemplated
using a prosthetic arm in the dance now
that hasn't come into play it because
you'd mentioned that it may later on
it's that right yeah you know because I
needed to be wearing it and getting more
comfortable with it okay so we don't
know if you know if and when it'll
happen just won't happen this week just
being on this show and doing what you're
doing is a massive inspiration to so
many people including veterans they've
been inspired they've been moved they
see that I took a risk you know I'm
showing some vulnerability I'm trying to
just step out of my comfort zone and do
something I've never done before
no was the dad of two boys in one girl
he is also the new face of Kenneth
Cole's fragrance mankind I guess I can
now add to my resume that I'm a model